She's clearly 24... 5?
45.
I can't tell anymore.
I'm gonna go talk to her to prove to you guys how delusional you are.
I'm sorry.
Do you mind if I sit here?
Yeah, be my guest.
I'll put your service to the test.
What?
Beauty and the Beast?
Oh, I've never seen it.
My parents always said I was too mature for Disney movies.
That's surprising.
Yeah, I actually read the fairy tale before I ever even knew there was a movie.
No way.
I had a weird childhood.
Oh, do you want some of my milk?
You're drinking milk?
Yeah, I have a bad calcium deficiency, which is also why sometimes I have to use this.
What?
Calcium supplements!
It can get pretty painful sometimes.
Like this year, for my 26th birthday, I had to be in a back brace.
Thank God!
Thank God for your fashion sense.
You know, because you can probably wear whatever and still make it look good.
Thank you.